[Musique]
reprenons le film de ce deuxième
confinement une semaine après son début
nous sommes le 6 novembre au service de
réanimation de l'hôpital bretonneau la
situation est déjà très tendu
[Musique]
actuellement il ya 27 patients dans le
service sur 27 lignes donc là pour
l'instant le secteur coville est
totalement occupés on est en train
d'ouvrir des possibilités
complémentaires dans d'autres
réanimation du chu et puis on a
également une unité non qu'ovide dont on
est en train de voir comment on pourrait
faire pour accepter des patients que vit
dedans donc là vous avez un sas d'entrée
dans la chambre ça c'est des
configurations qui peuvent être
différentes d'un service à l'autre
les chambres sont mises en dépréciant
pour éviter la sortie des germes
ça donne pas l'impression de ruches
parce qu'en fait les poubelles sont dans
bichon et c'est là que ça se passe
c'était beaucoup de technique de
ventilation artificielle pour lequel on
est amené à ventiler les patients sur le
ventre et donc ça demande beaucoup de
personnel parce qu'il faut retourner des
patients qui parfois sont des patients
obèses
en fait ma collègue là hier matin
c'était moi qui étais dans les chambres
colline jusqu'à midi et après il ya
après midi elle avait pris mon rôle est
donc ce matin en fait on a alterné cet
après-midi ce sera moi qui rentrera dans
l'est dans les chambres amélie est
infirmière en réanimation depuis dix ans
pour elle cette année 2020 commence à
être un peu longue
on est fatigué psychologiquement donc
faut vraiment se protéger au maximum
pour éviter de venir nous voir
même si on est très sympathique c'est
plus dur parce qu'en fait depuis mars on
est on est encore vide
on a toujours eu du coc vide voilà plus
ou moins nombreux on en a toujours eu
et puis en fait on ne décroche pas du
coleader on rentre chez nous ces colis
d'aussi partout donc voilà il ya aussi
la fatigue psychologique parce qu'on
sait que ça arrive là on sait que ça
touche l'indre et loire on sait que ça
peut toucher nos proches donc et aussi
cette fatigue l'acquis s'installer aux
côtés du malade isolé
marianne is et mélanie se bat pour
sauver la vie un travail rendu difficile
par les tenues de protection en un jour
en permanence c'est pénible d'être comme
ça en fait tout le temps et depuis ce
matin on est rentré à 8 heures on n'est
toujours pas sorti des chambres c'est
pour ça en fait qu'on fait des
roulements pour essayer de se soulager
un petit peu entre nous quoi ouais on
affirme la deuxième vague on se rend
compte qu'on a quand même plus de
travail que la première c'est plus
intense qu'on a plus vie tranquille
service aussi et que bah on va être vite
épuisé est vite submergé quoi il faut
une infirmière pour deux passions
qu'ovide au pic de la deuxième vague
avec près de 50 lits de réanimation à
tour ses 75 infirmières toutes les 24
heures
magali la semaine prochaine vous revenez
mardi vous serez donc en réa ii et vous
serez en doublure avec un des étudiants
anesthésistes qui arrivé là
mais semaine dernière les renforts sont
déjà là interne élèves infirmiers
infirmières et médecins d'autres
services du chu
quand c'est possible il faut soulager
d'autres hôpitaux d'autres régions plus
submergés
ce 13 novembre à l'aéroport de tours
deux malades arrivent de chambéry sous
assistance respiratoire
le lendemain c'est le ballet des
ambulances du samu au chu d'orléans il
faut libérer des places pour pouvoir
accueillir les cas les plus graves
compte tenu de tension assez extrêmes
sur nos lits de réanimation qu'ovide en
cette fin de semaine la cellule de crise
a décidé de transférer aujourd'hui
quatre patients de réanimation vers le
chu de tours qui dispose encore de deux
places pendant ce temps à tour dans une
chambre du service réanimation
on apprend les nouveaux gestes qui
accompagnent une intubation l'heure est
à la formation des renforts on va sauver
l'année pour être vraiment au casif
[Musique]
qu'on arrête
comme j'étais pas là la première vague
je me dois d'être présente ici à la
formation pour être au taquet pour la
deuxième vague des drogues nouveau bloc
opératoire il y avait beaucoup de
déprogrammation donc on était disponible
et puis voilà volontaires et motivés et
motivés exactement vous mettez vos deux
doigts en crochets bien tiré le menton
pour l'udc c'est la mâchoire et vous
mettez légèrement la tête en arrière à
les tâches des maladies infectieuses
d'autres renforcent préparer à utiliser
des systèmes d'oxygénation plus léger
avec le coronavirus les complications
sont avant tout respiratoire mais de
plus ça permet de rassurer tout le monde
oui ça permet aussi de réactiver surtout
les connaissances et du coup de sentir
plus à l'aise quand la situation se
présentera en espérant qu'elle se
présente pas on a mieux géré
deuxième vague puisqu'on avait
l'expérience de la première vague
notamment et avant tout pour les
patients avec une efficacité indéniable
des thérapeutiques basique un oxygène
éviter le plus possible intubation
animations les systèmes de ventilation
moins invasifs pour la deuxième vague
les cliniques privées participent le
dispositif régional l'idée éviter les
déprogrammations des opérations et des
consultations dans les autres services
aurélien sassard on a ouvert une unité
qu'ovide bien souvent ce sont des gens
n'ont rien ni matois donc ils vont être
souvent plus âgés avec plus de deux
pathologies chroniques
donc c'est ça la particularité de cette
structure
puisqu'ici on fait un petit peu du sc
médical de soins intensifs d'oxygénation
haut débit mais on fait pas de
réanimation nous sommes le 17 novembre
au pic de l'épidémie cette patiente
vient d'arriver ici les 24 lits ne reste
jamais vide dans le couloir une autre
patiente doit partir en urgence
c'est un passant qui s'est dégradée
malheureusement et du coup qu'on va
transférer vers l'hopital public pour
une unité de soins continus et si on a
un service de médecine donc on n'a pas
de structure ce copé et des cas besoin
d'un peu plus de surveillance de soi un
petit peu plus agressif on transfère les
patients général vers l'hôpital public
qui a un plateau technique un petit peu
plus développé dans le sas l'équipe de
la clinique ont jaune confie sa patiente
à celle du samu 45 en bleu un moment
difficile aussi pour les soigner et
maintenant c'est pas facile
humainement c'est vraiment dur ouais
mais bon on avait joué pour la première
vague le personnel soignant est allé en
renfort à l'hôpital cette fois les
malades et le co vides sont aussi à la
clinique
j'ai surtout l'impression la première
elle ne touchait pas de prêts là on a
été même le personnel a été étalée
touché en fait donc voilà on attrape et
on a faim moi personnellement j'ai eu
déjà un
c'est vrai que ça change la donne
heureusement pour jennifer prêt pour la
sortie il y a de temps en temps des
bonnes nouvelles jacqueline ressort
guéri
première ligne le coc vide est toujours
là l'inquiétude aussi on sait que la
misère la misère sociale
ce majoré avec cette crise qu vide avec
un nombre de chômeurs qui va augmenter
des sociétés qui vont fermer
donc tout ça c'est un impact et c'est un
impact aussi sur la santé donc ça va
revenir aussi à l'hôpital quelque part
après neuf mois sous que vides les
soignants espère ne pas vivre une
troisième vague le retour à une activité
normale à l'hôpital n'est de toute façon
pas pour demain